Question,
I think we're gonna lose a lot,
almost whatever we do because there's so
many species right now that are on the
brink of extinction.
I mean the break,
there are a number of trees,
species and flowering plants.
We should what you're known for one
individual
and there are a bird species for
example,
that are down to a few dozen individual.
We have to rhinoceros species two out of
the five that existed on the planet that
are 300 individual or fewer left.
So a lot of those we're going to lose
probably no matter what we do,
especially those which we don't even
know yet exist.
And we may never know they ever existed.
If they go extinct before we can learn
enough about the world's biodiversity.
But if we plan our use of the
environment in the future intelligently
and drive towards the goal of
sustainable development,
that is a development in producers,
increasing quality of life and security
for people,
uh,
but reduces the amount of materials and
energy that we're using up.
And if we intelligently plan a,
the establishment of reserves where,
uh,
we get the maximum protection for the
largest number of species.
And that's one thing.
The conservation organizations like
conservation international,
which we have served on the board,
are devoted.
Uh,
then I think we'll save a majority of
the remaining pictures.